problem is men can't be that is think
think about what I said okay no think
about think about ninety percent of
women have been at Birth Control at some
point in their life remember the ideal
woman if we're gonna go back to like
what men biologically want is a young
virgin right 95 of women have been on or
90 of women have been on birth control
90 um the average partner count and this
is including older women so it's
probably lower when you look at younger
women is between five to eight men which
historically would have been completely
Haram that's a lie
okay this is just what the numbers I
know everyone sometimes when I say that
way one out of three women has had an
abortion one out of three women have had
an STD so it's like this is even if you
become a one percent guy they don't
expect virgins because they're not
really there and even if they find one
they don't know if she's telling the
truth yeah